Ігор Козловський український учений
релігієзнавець громадський діяч який два
роки свого часу провів у полоні так
званої ДНР а також Ігор Анатолійович
член правління центр громадянських
свобод з правозахисної організації
Української яка цьогоріч стала одним із
лауреатів Нобелівської премії Миру тому
Ігорю Анатолійовичу по-перше Вітаю вас з
цією подією
всю Україну тому що Україна нарешті
отримала відзнаку такого рівня Це дійсно
подія як ви сприйняли цю новину це було
несподівано Да і всі очікували якоїсь
іншої для премії Але ж це
я б сказав така
подія яка можна сказати є
плід величезної роботи ну насамперед
центром громадянських свобод на чолі з
Олександром Матвійчук вона повинна тут
була стояти насправді того що це її її
внесок величезне людина з чуйним серцем
яка
жертовна працює на просторі
правозахисної роботи і давно працюють
тут повинна бути було Олександра
Романцова тобто ну всі інші ті хто так
чи інакше зробили цю премію реальністю
це командна робота
безумовно але ж організація за
Олександром Матвійчук вона неймовірна
неймовірна це може сказати абсолютно
щира Я спостерігаю давно за цією роботою
співпрацюю і можна сказати що не оця
жертовність вона відома не тільки в
Україні а в світі на рівні організації
об'єднаних націй ОБСЄ тобто ну всі
відомі платформи на них виступає і
доносить правду про Україну якраз
Олександр Матвієнко особливо це останнім
часом важливо коли
розслідування воєнних злочинів і не
просто розслідування ви розумієте це
робота вона титанічна
це треба почути кожну людину пропустити
її через себе через своє серце і
це величезна кількість свідчень людських
свідчень це трагедія людські і
чути їх
співчувати не просто робити певні там
реєстр знаєте механічно як можна робити
там моніторити і так далі а саме
співпереживати на співчувати
емпатія є також частиною цієї
правозахисної роботи і далі е-е це
трибунал для Путіна це також одна із
таких важливих напрямків роботи один із
найважливих краповиків роботи Центру
який також відомий в світі
питання яке хвилює зараз багатьох чи не
турбує вас сусідство по нобелівській
премії так би мовити адже лаурета ми
стали як ми знаємо правозахисники із
Росії і з Білорусії чи доречно ставити
українців росіян білорусів на один
п'єдестал ну для України от наше погляд
наша оптика ми ж травмовані цією війною
ми радикалізовані цією війною і у нас є
свій погляд на все що відбувається і ми
хотіли би щоб такий же погляд був у
світі тобто фокус фокус да на нас але ж
я розумію що є інша оптика і
нобелівський комітет дивиться взагалі на
все що відбувається тут на сході Європи
з тим щоб все з одного боку
підкреслити рівень України і вагу
України у світі з іншого боку це згадати
про жертви і лукашенківського режиму і
путінського скажімо і таким чином дати
послання послання тому ж Путіну Як
своєрідний такий подарунок на день його
сьогоднішнього народження для і сказати
що світ слідкує за цією
для тим як оце неметофізичне ареальне
зло намагається зруйнувати зруйнувати
взагалі
права і свободи людини вважається це
посланням своєрідним Путіним своєрідне
так безумовно безумовний з іншого боку
ось просто зберегла собі цитату
представниці норвезького комітету власне
Нобелівського комітету беріть траса
Андерсен вона заявила що ось ці три
організації лауреати вони уособлюють
бачення нобеля про мир та братерство Як
ви думаєте про який про яке про яке
протерство про який мир Тут взагалі
йдеться Ну я знову ж таки я можу
послатися на Олександра матовичу а вони
вже
опублікувала свій пост а і їде потягом з
Варшави вона написала що це наші е-е
братні організації чому Ну тому що ви
розумієте
заборона меморіалу в Росії да це це
подія і
люди які боролися і ми повинні віддати
належне що вони підтримувала Україну
завжди І це
представник весни білоруської
який знаходиться там в катівнях
лукашенківських і таким чином тут не те
братерство про яке ми зазвичай говоримо
під час війни Це мається на увазі що
ці люди
виборювали права і свободи людини вони є
правозахисниками і вони не є ворогами
України Це точно
воно і заслугою головним досягненням
центру громадянських свобод за весь час
роботи це те що вони робили цю роботу ми
можемо говорити що до 14 Але чи
починаючи з 2014 року вони були перші
найбільш активні і найбільш жертовні от
в цьому висвітленні в боротьбі за права
і буде людини І це безліч різних акцій Я
також приймав участь в цих акціях і при
до офісом президента і перед Верховною
Радою для того щоб приймали ті чи інші
закони які стосувалися саме право
свободи людини наприклад тож закон про
воєнних злочинців і саме завдяки
зусиллям центру громадянських свобод
дивіться цей закон був прийнятий і зараз
також оця от я б сказав
наполеглива жертовна відкрита
питання робота і адвокація України на
всіх рівнях міжнародних
його частку Як ви вважаєте нас щоб
доречно було витратити ці гроші Я думаю
що вони якраз на ці проекти які зараз
заплановані які втілюються в життя і
буде спрямовано Як колишній полонений
людина яка прийшла тяжкий шлях з 14-го
року як громадський активіст як
правозахисник Як ви вважаєте чи це
премія Миру допоможе Україні в її в
боротьбі за свою за свою незалежність за
права своїх людей
таким чином той самий
фокус на Україну Він посилюється і
ми постійно побоюємося що Україна може
зійти
зі шпальт
медіа може не про неї забувати от Саме
таке нагадування про Україну Що Україна
- це демократична держава що Україна -
це держава де права і свободи людини де
наступні права вони є важливими для
суспільства це є для нас таким внеском Я
б сказав так наше в наших бачення
України взагалі Ну коли йдеться про
премію Миру То коли вже буде в Україні
мир що для цього що для цього ще
потрібно
ви розумієте Да що для нас мирно
наступає після перемоги тобто перемога а
далі ми Чому Тому що це війна не тільки
збройна це війна ціннісна і путінський
режим намагається зруйнувати саме наше
цінності я виділив три цінності це
свобода це гідність ідентичність Чому
Тому що він хотів би забрати нашу
свободу він хотів би зруйнувати наших
гідність і знищити нашу ідентичність і
перед нами виклик або ми всі загинемо
або нічого немає і от тільки після нашої
Перемоги ми можемо говорити про мир